[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait partie des trois partenaires qui
ont initié le projet de manège avec alim
actes et la maison de l'emploi et de
l'insertion et de la formation
la messe de paris saclay la finalité de
l'action c'est de construire un manège
pour les guinguettes de l'yvette qui est
un festival qui a lieu depuis trente ans
sur les rives de l'yvette entre
palaiseau et villebon qui accueille
comme ça du public ça peut aller jusqu'à
dix mille personnes sur un week-end et
on s'est dit tiens ce serait bien qu'on
construise un manège pour ce festival
avec avec des gens s'est rapproché de la
mef qui nous a proposé de mettre en
place un dispositif d'insertion de
mobilisation ou de remobilisation pour
les demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
là c'est le module de construction il ya
deux autres modules qui sont des modules
de remobilisation avec un coach emploi
et un module de découverte des métiers à
la fois des métiers du recyclage mais
aussi les métiers du spectacle vivant et
de l'animation
ce qui est intéressant est ce qui est
vraiment sympa avec ce projet c'est
qu'il a mobilisé énormément de monde
il a intéressé beaucoup d'acteurs
du plateau de saclay à la fois les
acteurs de l'insertion qui ont donné des
matériaux mais aussi les entreprises
comme bouygues construction qui a donné
tout le matériel de sécurité
toutes les deux pays on est accueilli la
dent les un bâtiment qui appartient à le
pea donc l'établissement public
d'aménagement du plateau de saclay qui a
aussi trouvé ce projet intéressant et
nous a mis à la disposition ses locaux
pour pouvoir le réaliser
ce sera vraiment un manège écologique du
début jusqu'à la fin de la récupération
du recyclage des matériaux alors à son
fonctionnement
[Musique]